بين جبال الهيمالايا وهضبه التبت وضع قابل
للاشتعال في اي لحظه وضع هش وخطير بين
الصين والهند وفق وصف وزير الخارجيه
الهندي فالدولتان تحشودان القوات المسلحه
قرب المنطقه الحدوديه المتنازع عليها وهي
لاداخ التابعه لاقليم جامو وكشمير
والمقابل لها في الصين اقليم اكسايتشن
الواقع على هضبه التبت
ما يزال الوضع هشا للغايه لان هناك اماكن
تنتشر فيها قواتنا على مقربه من بعض ولذلك
فمن حيث التقييم العسكري الوضع خطير جدا
نزاع يعود لايام الوجود البريطاني في
الهند حول الخط الحدودي بين البلدين اذ
يدعي كل من الطرفين تبعيه المنطقه له لكنه
تفاقم في 2017 عندما شقت الصين طريقا
عسكريا على هضبه استراتيجيه قرب الحدود
وتلتها اشتباكات في 2020 اثر بناء الهند
طريقا على هضبه في لاداخ والتي خلفت قتلى
بين الجيشين
محاولات الهند لتطوير البنيه التحتيه في
المنطقه المتنازع عليها تثير حافظه الصين
وابرزها طريق تؤدي الى وادي جالوان احد
المواقع التي وقعت فيها الاشتباكات
الاخيره خاصه مع الغاء الهند لوضع جامو
وكشمير الخاص والغاء الحكم الذاتي الممنوح
لها الخلاف الهندي الصيني تحول في اكثر من
مره لاشتباك حدودي اوقع ضحايا والمخاوف
مندلاع صراع اكبر ما تزال وارده اذا عمر
العربيه